we've used our earnings growth to invest
billions of dollars in the u.s. to
create even more American jobs we're
investing a hundred million dollars to
build a line of backs in the u.s. later
this year this product will be assembled
in Texas to include components from
Illinois and Florida and rely on
quipment produced in Kentucky and
Michigan we've constructed one of the
world's largest data centers in North
Carolina reflecting our commitment to
the environment the data center is
powered by the largest solar farm and
fuel cell of its kind in the u.s. we're
building data centers in Oregon and
Nevada a new campus in Texas and a new
headquarters in Cupertino with all this
growth and investment to the best of our
knowledge Apple has become the largest
corporate income taxpayer in America
last year our US federal cash effective
tax rate was thirty point five percent
and we paid nearly six billion dollars
in cash to the US Treasury that's more
than 16 million dollars each day and we
expect to pay even more this year I'd
like to explain to the subcommittee very
clearly how we view our responsibilities
with respect to taxes Apple has real
operations in real places with Apple
employees selling real products to real
customers we pay all the taxes we owe
every single dollar we not only comply
with the laws but we comply with the
spirit of the laws we don't depend on
tax gimmicks we don't move intellectual
property offshore and use it to sell our
products back to the United States to
avoid taxes we don't stash money on some
Caribbean island we don't move our money
from our foreign subsidiaries to fund
our US business in order to skirt the
repatriation tax our foreign
subsidiaries
70% of our cash because of the very
rapid growth of our international
business we use these earnings to fund
our foreign operations such as spending
billions of dollars to acquire equipment
to make apple products and to finance
construction of apple retail stores
around the world under the corporate
under the current US corporate tax
system it would be very expensive to
bring that cash back to the United
States
unfortunately the tax code has not kept
up with the digital age the tax system
handicaps American corporations in
relation to our foreign competitors who
don't have such constraints on the free
movement of capital